the exponentially more disturbing
revelations about what's going on at the
Trump White House behind the scenes are
starting to find their way into my
dreams or I guess I would call them
nightmares that that's probably a better
term for them at night and a recent
report maybe the most disturbing yet the
other night at 3:00 a.m. which is
usually when things seem to happen at
the White House Donald Trump was
confused about the dollar is a strong
dollar good for the American economy or
is a weak dollar good for the American
economy let's skip that the president
being so confused about the implications
of a strong or weak dollar is in and of
itself really really scary let's put
that aside for a second to get to the
really bizarre part in Trump's three
a.m. confusion he made a call at 3:00
a.m. not to an economist not to someone
who knows about the strength of the
dollar and its implications with regard
to the economy but to his national
security adviser retired Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn according to two
different sources familiar with the
incident Flynn's expertise is of course
not in macroeconomics but rather in
counterintelligence so he did the right
thing and said to Trump honestly at 3:00
a.m. I don't know maybe you should talk
to an economist reportedly Trump didn't
like that when he called a retired
member of the military at 3:00 a.m. for
advice on currency fluctuations the guy
didn't have a strong answer for him how
can you be a master negotiator
international businessman which Trump
claims to be and not understand the
basic implications of a strong versus
weak dollar I really just wonder what
prompted this thought to come to his
head at 3 o'clock in the morning - you
mean maybe Fox News was playing some
sort of rerun that covered this topic
and he was up late watching that because
that's what prompted his flag-burning
tweet at I think 6 o'clock in the
morning when that was we're seeing
something Rachel that we don't often see
from administrations this early on which
is you often see leaks from people who
are sort of trying to help themselves
within the administration write leaks to
make other people look bad for posturing
etc but these are leaks that we're
seeing from people that are just scared
by Donald Trump's behavior here's a
quote from Elliot Cohen former State
Department official in there george w
bush
I've been in this town for 26 years I
have never seen anything like this I
genuinely do not think this is a
mentally healthy president and then a
White House aide who asked to remain
unnamed said to the Huffington Post that
because Trump doesn't like to read long
memos now they give him a single page
with nine really spread out simple
language bullet points light reading for
Trump this is the only way he'll take in
data in written form yeah I actually and
this is not a joke my grandmother is
very hard of hearing and she has some
some early onset dementia so when I'm
trying to communicate with her I type
out a list of large words about nine
bullets so this is very frightening
that's how Trump aids are communicating
with him and really random little things
are either really pleasing or upsetting
Trump and it's concerning to AIDS Trump
told the New York Times that he's
fascinated with the phone system in the
White House for example but at the same
time the hand towels aboard Air Force
One were not soft enough for Trump and
that's something that he expended some
energy thinking about he's obsessed with
how his aides are doing on cable TV most
presidents aren't for example regularly
watching the press Secretary's daily
briefing in this case Sean Spicer Trump
apparently is watching that regularly
this is all very disturbing behavior
isn't it it's all just so superficial -
I mean what your spokes people are
saying on cable news how the towels are
at the White House I mean pretty much
anyone else would be flattered to live
in the White House and I think he sees
it as a downgrade yeah well I mean if
you're used to everything being covered
in gold plating in Trump Tower if you go
to the White House and it's appointed in
a slightly less ostentatious way which
is crazy that were even saying that I
guess it is sort of a downgrade I mean
but also I I think it the bigger issue
even though I we already know this it's
kind of just setting it in stone is that
he completely bypassed doing any work on
his own such as googling what does a
strong or weak dollar mean and this is
how he's going to conduct himself during
the whole presidency he's going to say I
don't need to do any work I can just
rely on people who have no information
the topic that I'm interested in to do
it for me who hasn't called am a former
member of the military at 3:00 a.m. to
discuss macroeconomic I mean I did last
week but I wasn't going to tell people
about it
also I've been reading that Trump heads
up to the residence in the white house
around 6:30 p.m. what I would give to be
a fly on the wall from 6:30 p.m. until
the 3:00 a.m. phone call to generals to
ask about currency rates like what could
be going on during those eight and a
half hours should we be concerned that
he's not sleeping that much he has long
said he only sleeps like four hours a
night and only needs that and he's proud
of it which is pretty widely debunked by
science like there is a range of numbers
of hours of sleep that are sort of like
the natural restorative sleep for people
but for is outside of that range I've
not seen any signs that suggest on an
indefinite basis people can be properly
rested with four hours a night right no
it can't and there's all of the studies
that we've seen time and time and time
again about either overnight shifts or
less sleep leading to earlier death
rates and I think people like Donald
Trump or that case in point while you
should probably sleep more yeah if
there's ever been a case for sleeping
loft sleeping more and the importance of
rest it's when you see Donald Trump call
in general at 3:00 a.m. to say hey I'm
the president can you just fill me in is
a strong dollar good or bad
I think if we've ever seen the effects
of sleep deprivation it's it's that